la famille touahri s'agrandit le parc
zoologique yvelinois qui recense plus de
800 animaux et 120 espèces enregistré 37
naissances en 2016 dont une dizaine
depuis le début du mois de mai on essaie
aussi de faire en sorte que les
naissances arrive à un moment où c'est
aussi le plus facile pour la survie du
petit c'est à dire qu'un petit petites
antilopes qui va naître en plein hiver
quand il fait moins dix ses chances de
survie sur un petit peu plus faible que
si l'aînée maintenant et que ben il a
tout l'été pour devenir un peu plus fort
et donc à bord aborder l'hiver un peu
plus facilement évidemment ça coïncide
avec la période où le public est là on
va pas s'en plaindre
c'est forcément plus intéressant pour un
visiteur de voir de voir des animaux des
bébés
cette année les quatre cent mille
visiteurs annuels pourront observer des
bébés wallaby des ouistitis des zèbres
des bises ou encore des oryx d'arabie
cacher le plus souvent dans les pattes
de leur mère ces naissances sont
toujours bien accueillis par les 60
employés du parc c'est pas forcément un
critère de que l'animal est bien parce
que les animaux c'est ça fait partie de
leur vie de se reproduire
donc voilà les autres animaux vous
mettez à mal une semaine globalement
souvent ça va se reproduire mais
évidemment quelle que soit la naissance
on est content donc là quand on a des
petits des petits du goût des petits
chevaux des petits trucs comme ça oui
forcément on est content de nouvelles
naissances devraient avoir lieu dans les
prochaines semaines chez les zèbres les
antilopes et légumes chaque année le
parc accueille entre 70 et 80 nouveaux
pensionnaires